the ultimate game changer in this will
be a vaccine the same way a vaccine for
other diseases that was Courage's in the
past that now we don't even worry dr.
Anthony found her there clearly Johnson
& Johnson working on a vaccine that
could be available for trial maybe in
the fall dr. Paul Stoffels is the chief
scientific officer for Johnson & Johnson
at a Belgium today induct thank you for
your time give us the status for your
trial in the lab where do you stand as
of now well we started 15 of January on
working on the vaccine in the laboratory
with about hundred people so today we
selected our lead candidate earlier this
week and now we start doing the
preclinical work as well as the
upscaling to be able to start clinical
trials early September hopefully with
data early next year at the fastest end
of the year in order to be able to start
expanded to use in emergency use
circumstances so doctor why did you
start in January what were you seeing in
this vaccine then well we started by
when we received the code the code was
published of the sequence of the virus
by the Chinese that gave us the
information on how the virus looked like
and from the code on paper we were able
to synthesize certain pieces of the
virus which gives us the fastest
possibility to start working on a
vaccine and we have an existing plan a
vaccine platform which we have used in
HIV in RSV Ebola and Zika and so we used
the same platform which is a vector
which we use we constructed that factor
with Kovac 19 and now our 10 weeks late
that we are able to select the vaccine
which we can bring forward into clinical
trials in September let me try just a
real technical questionnaire on a date
what was the day that the Chinese
provided this vaccine for you do you
recall that not exactly I know but it
was published and at that moment we were
able but it was somewhere early of
January
not so much later or we had we had
patients in in Europe and and also in
the US and we were able to get a vaccine
the life vaccine out of the patients who
we're on the ground in Europe and us for
continued to work on it and so we have
very quickly were able to further
identify the virus but we started from
the code to the Chinese publish the
genetic code early January doctor two
more quick questions here you've worked
on HIV years past a bola you mentioned
that as well well what is different with
koban 19 that you found
well Kovac 19 is is is of course
extremely fast spreading we were working
15 years ago on SARS where we made an
antibody in those days as well I started
to work on a vaccine but SARS
disappeared and so we had some insights
on what to do
this virus now is less lethal than SARS
but so much more spreading that it
causes so many more dead because it's
affecting the population worldwide yeah
clearly that's why we go ahead sorry I
apologize about that no and that's why
why when we when we start the
development of a vaccine now we have to
immediately get going or manufacturing
because we need to have hundreds of
millions of vaccines available when we
come up with the clinical data and
that's why we started investing
immediately in additionals in in
additional sites and we kick off the
manufacturing now fully at risk and as
you know probably we had and we have
made a collaboration with the US
government and together invest in 1
billion dollar and the objective now is
preparing everything to be able to
produce or 1 billion vaccines next year
just one last quick question once you
start testing on humans how long before
you know hey we've got it well it
probably will take four or five months
depending on where in the world at that
moment the vaccine is still sorry the
the infection is still ongoing so that
we can do clinical trials fast so we
need four or five months to get to fully
the clinical results in order to start
vaccinating people onward here great
gasps thanks for coming on good luck to
you your team okay at Johnson & Johnson
dr. Paul Stoffels thank you from
Brussels today thank you sir